i've sent out a written statement i'm
really here to answer any questions you
have on the
process
or procedure uh i'll say what was in the
written statement if it's helpful to you
which is simply to say
that the threshold of 15 of the
parliamentary party seeking a vote of
confidence in the prime minister has
been passed therefore a vote of
confidence will take place
within the rules of the 1922 committee
that vote will take place this evening
in the house of commons between six and
eight o'clock
and we will announce the result shortly
thereafter uh there will be arrangements
for proxy votes for any colleagues who
can't be present in person uh in
westminster and will notify colleagues
of those arrangements in the near future
did you communicate the news directly to
the prime minister how did he react
i i'm not going to go into detail of
that
i have followed the rules that we have
in place
i notified the prime minister yesterday
that the threshold had been reached and
we agreed uh the timetable uh for a
confidence vote to take place
and
he shared my view
which is also in line with the rules
that we have in place that that vote
should happen as soon as could
reasonably take place
and that would be today how many letters
have you received uh i don't divulge
that um but the threshold of 15 has been
passed uh
it's slightly complicated because some
colleagues had asked specifically uh
that it should not be until the end of
the jubilee celebrations so did some of
them post-date their letters so it's not
to interrupt the jubilee
i think that's not a bad description of
what was taking place and that's when
the threshold
was breached therefore we
reached a point where i could
communicate with the prime minister
yesterday uh which i which i did and as
i said
he agreed with me uh that we should
conduct votes as quickly as we
reasonably can prime minister
it's always an open invitation to the
prime minister to come and speak to the
committee uh so if he wishes to
we will arrange that meeting this
afternoon
have you put one in yourself a letter
i'm not going to answer that question
but uh
i think technically it would be possible
but it was like the old thing to do
are you surprised at the speed with
which number 10 is moving you've seen a
few of these come and go these events
i'm not surprised by the speed our rules
say should be done as soon as is
reasonable in the circumstances uh when
we held a vote on
theresa may's position
in december 2018
we spoke the evening before and we held
a vote the next day
so you know i suppose it's in line with
recent precedent and i think it's
good for everybody to get these things
out of the way as quickly and efficient
as as possible how long could a contest
actually take if there is one at the end
of it i'm not going to speculate about
leadership elections
we're holding a vote of confidence and
it will take place today and uh you will
have a result this evening
uh
well i i a confidence vote obviously
will provide a clear answer the party
will have confidence in the leadership
or not have confidence in the leadership
that's the question that will be before
my colleagues today
technically it's possible for rules to
be changed but the rule at present is
that there will be a year of a period of
over grace break in terms of foreign
leadership i think my constituents have
been enjoying the jubilee as we all have
i think unless you've got any other
questions of detail
thank you